Today, we are going to discuss some
extremely controversial topics.
And because this is going to go on
YouTube, there's certain words I cannot
say.
So, just a warning you, I will write
down these words, but I will not say
them because if I do say them, then I'll
get censored on YouTube.
Today, we are going to look at how evil
triumphs. Why is the world so evil?
And there is going to be a lot of
extremely disturbing topics we're going
to discuss.
Um but you're mature, and it's important
that we discuss these topics in order to
understand how the world works.
So, let's just start. Um
and we will do a lot of speculation and
theorizing in this class. So, do not
take this as gospel. Do not believe this
is the truth. The entire point of this
class is to help you develop the
theories and the ideas to better
understand the world. These are tools.
Okay, this is not truth. This These are
tools. All right.
So, the first question I have for you is
what What is happening in Israel?
Right now, as you know,
Israel is
besieging, bombarding Gaza. You might
have seen the videos on social media. It
is disturbing. It is terrible what is
happening. The word that is happening
The word that we use for what is what is
happening in
Gaza is this word. You are not allowed
to say this word on YouTube, but that is
the intention.
What I will argue though is that the
truth is far more disturbing than this.
What is really happening in Gaza is a
ritual
sacrifice.
And this happens quite often in human
history.
If you go back and you look at the real
history of humanity, this happens quite
often. Some of the most um
famous examples are the Aztecs.
We've dug up temples of the Aztecs, and
inside the temples are thousands and
thousands of human skulls.
So, before they went to war, they
practiced human sacrifice. They would
commit mass murder of their enemies in
public. So, the Aztecs were really
famous for this.
The Phoenicians,
uh specifically the Carthaginians,
uh we will discuss some later this
semester, but the Phoenicians were also
famous for a particular type of
sacrifice, which is
child sacrifice.
The Romans
wrote histories
insulting the Phoenicians for practicing
this sort of sacrifice. But, the Romans
themselves
practiced human sacrifice.
What they would do is that after every
major war, they would capture all the
major leaders of their enemies, and they
would parade their enemies through the
streets of Rome.
This is something called a triumph.
At the end of the triumph, they would
gather enemies at the Temple of Jupiter.
Jupiter is their god. And then, they
would strangle to death
their enemies.
That's sacrifice. That's human
sacrifice. They didn't call it that,
okay? And they sort of disguised it, but
we know for a fact that they did do
this.
So,
the question for us is
why is it
that this happens? Why do the Aztecs do
it? Why do the Phoenicians do it? Why do
the Romans do it? And why is it today
the Israelis do it
in
Gaza? And remember, okay?
Um what
the Israelis are doing is quite horrific
because it is really ritual of
sacrifice. Why? Because 47%
Oh, almost half of the population of
Gaza is under 18 years old.
So, the majority of people who are
getting killed are in fact children.
What is most striking or blatant about
what's happening in Gaza is that we can
all see it for ourselves.
And it's almost as though
the Israelis want us to see it and want
us to hate them.
Right? You can see over the world
popular opinion is turning against
Israel. You have these popular protests
all around the world protesting what is
happening in Palestine.
If they really want to do this, right?
There are actually much more effective
ways of doing this. For example, you
could just poison their water.
Or you could
poison the air so that everyone in Gaza
gets a
fast cancer, right? We have the
technology to do this.
So, so Israel could do it this secretly
and no one would talk about it. And in
20 years time, 30 years time, the
population population of Gaza would all
be gone. It would be a very secret
right? Instead,
they choose to do this in front of the
world.
And my argument to you is that this is
intentional.
They want the world to hate them.
Because
by doing this, they create the ultimate
taboo.
Right? It we find this disgusting and
contemptuous, so the entire world will
unite against Israel.
But guess what?
That's what their religion wants.
In the
extreme form of Jewish eschatology or
the religion,
they believe that at the end of the
world, Israel will fight the entire
world and God will help Israel triumph
in the end.
So what's really happening in Gaza is
that there are extremists within the
Israel government who want to accelerate
the process
of the end of the world where Israel
will face
the world. And if you think about it,
the entire idea of this ritual sacrifice
is to unite the Israeli population.
And what's extremely disturbing and
horrifying about it is that this works.
Why? Well, let's use an analogy. Okay?
The analogy is this.
In Chinese history,
the most popular military stratagem is
to fight with a river behind your back.
You guys have heard of this strategy,
right? Where okay,
um an army is losing, okay? It's it's
being scattered by the enemy. So what
the general does is forces the army to
retreat to a river. And now with a river
blocking your escape, you have a choice.
You can either drown in the river or you
can fight to the death.
And most soldiers will choose to fight
to the death. And so, at this point, the
soldiers are unified. They're
galvanized. They're energized. And then
they find a surge of energy to go and
destroy their enemy. Okay, this is the
most popular military stratagem in
ancient Chinese history. And guess what?
It's the same as
Israel doing this right now in Gaza.
It's the same logic.
Yes, you you have a question?
So, what is the river for the Israel?
Like Yeah, that that that's a good
question. What's a river right here,
right? The river is a taboo, right?
What's the worst thing you can do in my
society?
Killing children, guys.
Right?
So, there's no exit for Israel. You
either go all the way or the world comes
and destroys you anyway.
And in fact, what's really interesting
is that if you go online,
you will see Israelis going around the
world and causing trouble everywhere.
They're going to start fights. They're
they shout death to the Arabs on public
buses in the Western world.
It's intentional. They want to unite
themselves by dividing the world, by
angling the world.
Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. So,
this is all very disturbing. And I want
to slowly unpack with you to reveal to
you how this works. Okay? So, uh to do
this, what I'm going to do is I'm going
to use a thought experiment.
The thought experiment is this.
Let's just say
that there's an island. We don't know
where the island is,
but it's an island.
And there's no escape from the island.
And on the island, there the center is a
hill and it's safe. But everywhere else,
you have these flesh-eating monkeys
roaming everywhere.
Okay? The problem is that on this
island,
uh the resources you need to survive,
trees, food, and rivers, the monkeys are
there. Okay? There's one safe spot in
the in the center, but everywhere else,
if you want resources, you have to go
fight these monkeys. They're
flesh-eating monkeys. They want to kill
you. They want to eat you. And there's
an infinite number of them.
Now, let's just say that one day, for
whatever reason, okay, we don't know
why, but 100
men aging and they range from 15 to 65
years old, okay?
They are mysteriously transplanted onto
this island in the safe spot.
They come from different countries. They
do not speak the same language. They are
of different ethnicities. They are all
poor people in their countries. They
don't have much education.
So, they're there and they realize
quickly that the situation is utterly
hopeless. There's no escape from this
island.
These monkeys are everywhere and they
are tough
warriors.
And
the situation looks bleak. They don't
even speak the same language. They don't
have a common culture.
So, at this point, you would imagine
that they would feel hopeless and just
lie down and die.
But in reality, what happens is the
opposite. What happens is that in this
hopeless situation, they find a drive, a
purpose,
a spirit to fight for each other.
And what will happen really quickly,
okay, and this is really interesting, is
the first thing that they will do is
they will develop a common language.
They don't speak the same language. Some
speak Chinese, some speak English, some
speak Spanish, some speak Russian, it
doesn't matter. They will very quickly
develop a common language.
And then what they will do is with this
common language, they will start to tell
each other stories
of where they come from.
And then these stories will become a
common
myth. A founding myth of why they're
here.
And they come to believe that God has
chosen them to save the world, and
that's why they're here.
Then what they will do is
with this new religion, they will start
develop rituals
to reinforce this religion.
These rituals include sex.
Okay? So these men will have sex.
And the reason why is create intimacy
and bonding
among them. And there'll be a lot of
religious rituals as well.
Another thing that they will do
is pick a leader. There's a hundred of
them, they need a leader to organize
them.
And so we can imagine that during the
leadership election, everyone gets up to
speak. Now, the man who's 65,
he is wise. He has experience, he has
strategies. So he delivers a very
powerful speech, inspiring everyone, and
telling people how they can survive
against the flesh-eating monkeys, okay?
So he's really smart.
Then suddenly you have a man appear
who's 15 years old or 16 or 17, okay?
He is not articulate. He has no ideas.
What what he does is this, he stands in
front of everyone
and he's bold and he's brave and he
looks at everyone without saying a word.
He shows them his hand. Okay? He shows
them his hand. Then from his pocket, he
takes out a knife.
Okay? And then he cuts off his hand
in front of everyone.
And he does not cry. He just looks at
everyone
as though nothing happened.
Let me ask you this question.
Who does everyone pick to be their
leader?
The second person obviously, right? The
man who has shown sacrifice and
commitment and devotion to everyone
else.
The old man has ideas and he will become
the advisor
to the leader, but the leader is the man
who is most willing to die for everyone
else.
And so in this situation, the bravest
among them will come and emerge as the
leader.
And as such,
what will happen is
that these people, these men, will
become extremely inspired and devoted.
Even though they are weak, they will
learn to become strong.
Even though they are poor and
uneducated, they will learn to be wise
and clever and strategic.
They will rapidly transform themselves.
And ultimately, what will happen is the
idea of cohesion.
Cohesion like brothers, cohesion like a
family. They will understand each other
even though they're different from
different cultures, even though they
have different backgrounds. They will
understand each other better than they
understand their own children and their
own wives.
And this cohesion will lead to something
called synchronicity.
Synchronicity.
Synchronicity is when people
act in unison together. Okay? So, a very
simple example of synchronicity is a
sports team, right? When you watch a
soccer match,
how is that soccer soccer team able to
work together? Well, because of
synchronicity, because their minds are
alike. It's what we call a hive mind.
And this allows for something called
telepathy.
They're able literally
to think and act as one.
So, let me give you an example of this.
Let's just say one They're like these
men They're sleeping, but one of them
wanders off to collect wood.
And then he's attacked by monkeys.
It doesn't matter if he screams because
he's too far away.
Would his comrades know that he's in
danger?
They would.
Okay? And the example here is
let's just say you're a mother.
And you have children, okay? And one of
them goes off to France
on vacation.
But then, while he's in France, he gets
hit by a car and is hospitalized. Would
you as a mother know that he that your
son is in danger?
Would you feel it?
He hasn't called you.
You don't know about this, but in your
heart would you know it?
The answer is yes, you would know it.
You would feel something is wrong. You
would get on the phone and try to call
your son.
You would
You can't reach your son, you would call
the police. Okay? You don't know what's
happening, but something in your heart
is telling you,
"I need to get in touch with my son."
And that's how the hive mind
works. That's how synchronicity works.
Let's look Let's look at another
example. Let's just say that one day
you There's 10 of you and you're off
collecting wood.
And then suddenly you're attacked by 100
flesh-eating monkeys. There's a bridge
that you've created, okay? It's a rope
bridge. Nine get across the bridge, all
right? But you're the last person, okay?
And all the monkeys are about to descend
on you.
And you know that if the monkeys get
across,
your comrades are dead.
So, what you What do you do in the
situation?
Yeah, you you cut the rope, okay? You
die. You don't think about it.
You just kill yourself because what
matters is not your life, what matters
is the family, what matters is the team.
And we know all this because in war,
what often happens is in trench warfare,
the other uh the enemy will throw a
grenade into the trench, right? There's
not enough time to get that to pick up
that uh grenade and throw it away. So,
what soldiers do is they will jump on
the grenade and absorb the explosion,
thus killing himself. It happens
instantaneously. No one thinks about it,
you just do it because what matters is
saving your comrades.
And this is what happens.
Okay?
A synchronicity develops where it's
almost as though you're able to reach
read each other's minds.
And they keep on doing this for like 10,
20 years.
And then suddenly, okay, let's continue
our thought experiment. Suddenly,
you are transported
back
to the real world. As though nothing
happened, but you have memories
of what happened.
Okay, does that make sense?
Okay? You've experienced 20 years of
hell on Monkey Island.
You've developed the capacity to work
together.
You have a hive mind. You're really
energized. You're really inspired.
You're really driven. You have a new
religion
all to yourself.
Now, suddenly, you're all trans-
transported back to your
real world, your old life.
Okay? Now, what would happen? What would
happen is that the hundred of you would
want to come together again, right?
And you would share your experience,
your rituals, your religion with your
children and your grandchildren. And
quickly, over time, what will happen is
that
you guys will conquer the world.
You will become the secret elite.
The world is yours. There may be
presidents. There may be famous people,
but secretly, you're the ones who are in
control. Your children, your
grandchildren, your great-grandchildren
will inherit this legacy, and they are
the ones who truly control power in the
world.
Does that make sense?
All right. Yeah, question here.
Like if we
Like if
when the time if this person really
transferred back to the real reality,
what if that time already have a elite
leader that like you are just a peasant,
but not
a leader? Okay, yeah, that's a good
question. I've already told you this,
okay? On the surface, there are leaders,
but the real power are you guys.
Okay? And I'll explain why. All right?
Now, um what's also interesting is that
um while you're on this island, you will
develop certain rituals that are very
strange, but are important if you want
to maintain unity. Okay? So, for
example,
one strange ritual is
the funeral ritual.
The funeral ritual.
Um
the idea here is that when someone
sacrifices himself, you have a huge
funeral to celebrate with that person.
And this may involve you cutting that
person into different pieces and eating
that person.
Okay? But you you you will develop
really strange rituals.
Okay. Does that make sense? Okay. So,
I'm I'm going to answer your question.
Uh why are these guys in charge and not
the real leaders of society?
But first, I want to give you some
historical analogies to this. Okay? How
do you know that what I'm saying is
correct?
Well, let's look at certain analogies of
his in history.
All right.
So,
Sparta.
Sparta is one of the most famous mili-
military societies in world history.
Sparta is a city-state in ancient
Greece.
And you may have heard of Sparta.
Um a movie about Sparta was made called
300. I'm not sure if you guys have seen
the movie 300.
But 300 is really about 300 Spartan
soldiers who are fighting millions, not
millions, but hundreds of thousands of
Persian soldiers. Persia is invading
mainland Greece. They fight at a place
called Thermopylae.
The Battle of Thermopylae. And this is a
a pass
into mainland Greece. The Greeks have to
hold this position if they are to
prevent invasion.
Okay? 300 Spartan soldiers, backed by
thousands of other Greek soldiers, make
a last stand in this pass.
They are overwhelmed by the Persian
invasion and rather than run, like most
people, the 300 soldiers make a final
stand. Their leader is Leonidas
and he tells them, "We will fight to the
death.
They all fight to the death
and they're all massacred.
And the Persians
take Leonidas' head, cut it off, and put
on a on a pike to warn the Greeks we are
merciless.
Eventually, Greeks
um inspired by the sacrifice of
Leonidas, they will repel invasion and
destroy the
um invaders.
So, how do we get this culture?
Okay? Well,
the education system of the Spartans is
really interesting. It's really
disturbing, actually. So,
young boys at age five and six, they're
taken away from their homes.
And they are put in a school run by
older boys. Okay, so so the older boys
are maybe like 10, 11.
And so, what happens, as you can
imagine, is the older boys beat the crap
out of the younger boys, okay? From day
one, there's no education. They're not
learning anything. All that's happening
is the older boys are just beating the
crap out of the younger boys.
But because this is happening, we call
this like hazing, okay?
This happens actually a lot um among
fraternities and sports teams.
They're When they're getting the crap
beaten out of them, it builds
solidarity. It builds brotherhood. So,
these young boys who are five and six,
they learn to love each other because
only by helping each other can they
survive the brutality.
Okay?
Then what happens is when they learn
when they become 11, 12, 13, when they
hit puberty,
this is really interesting, they become
mentored, okay? Mentored
by an older soldier, an older Spartan
soldier, who's maybe 28, 29, 30. But he
has a family.
They become lovers.
They have sex with each other.
And this builds group solidarity. Okay,
so during hazing phase, these young boys
learn to trust each other.
They learn how to bond with each other.
Uh during the mentorship phase, these
young boys learn to think like in a hive
mind, okay? They learn to be part of a
larger group.
Then when they
um turn 18,
they um
graduate, okay?
And in order graduate,
what they do is this.
They have a mission.
So, the Spartans um have slaves called
helots, okay? These are just people that
they've conquered and who are now work
as slaves in the fields for them, okay?
They're like serfs.
So, there are lots of rules governing
the helots. An important rule is curfew.
So, if it's dark at night, you cannot be
outside the house.
If you are outside the house at night,
you could be
um executed, okay? So, to as a
graduation mission, these young soldiers
hide in the fields at night.
Okay? They hide in the fields and they
wait for
the sun to go down. So, it's now dark.
And they look for helots to come back
because they're late. And what they'll
do is they'll sneak up behind the helots
and cut their throats.
Okay, this is basically sacrifice.
Okay, human sacrifice.
So, the Spartans did this as well. It's
a very common thing.
And what this does is it builds
group cohesion leading to synchronicity.
Only there are thousand thousands of
city-states in Greece. Only Sparta did
this.
And it made everyone think Sparta was
disgusting. Everyone hated Sparta.
But it kept Sparta unified. And And And
Sparta into the dominant military power
in Greece at that time.
Okay?
What happened then is Thebes, another
city-state
in
um Greece, they would copy the Spartan
Spartan system, okay? But they made it
voluntary. So, if if So, in Sparta, you
have to be an elite to be part of the
system.
But in Thebes, anyone could join the
Okay? And they called the system the
Sacred Band.
Um of 300 soldiers. And they were,
again,
lovers, okay? But this is really
important for you guys to understand. At
this time in history, there's no concept
of homosexuality. It was perfectly
permissible. No one cared if you had sex
with
men or animals or whatever, okay? It was
not a big deal. This comes much later,
in modern times. Back then, this was not
considered homosexuality was not
considered a concept. Okay? If you're
out in the field, if you're out at war
for like years and years and there's no
women around,
you're going to have sex with other men.
It's a very natural thing to do.
Okay? Doesn't mean you're homosexual,
okay? So, the Sacred Band of Thebes
became the dominant military power
after Sparta, okay? It's called the
Sacred Band.
And they were like the
um vanguard. They were the spearhead.
They would be the first in battle. And
they were so ferocious that their
enemies would run away, okay?
Then what happened is that Macedonia
would
copy the Theban system.
Um who's the most famous Macedonian in
the world? Do you guys know?
Which Macedonian is the most famous ever
in human history? You know the name, but
you may not know he's Macedonian.
Alexander the Great, okay? His father is
Philip II.
Philip II is the one that actually built
the greatest army in the world, the
Macedonianian army. And it was Alexander
the Great, his son, who would take this
army and conquer Persia. Okay, we'll
learn this later on.
But, Philip II learned learned all this
from Thebes.
And at first, Macedonia and Thebes were
allies, but Philip II was very
ambitious. So, then he started to
want He wanted to conquer all of
mainland Greece.
And in 338
uh BCE, at the Battle of
uh Chaeronea,
Macedonia fought against the combined
might of Thebes and Athens.
And Macedonia destroyed Thebes and
Athens, okay? Because Macedonia
basically copied the system from Sparta
and Thebes.
At this point,
Macedonia should have destroyed the
entire Theban and Athenian army.
But, when all was lost,
the Sacred Band,
they stood in the middle of the field.
And they blocked the advance of
Macedonian charge
so that everyone could escape back into
the cities.
They did not fear death. They welcomed
death.
Okay? For them, what mattered was honor
and sacrifice.
And that's
how you create
the greatest army in the world.
Okay? Does that make sense? So, these
historical analogies
give credence to our thought experiment.
Okay.
Now, we're going to look at a question,
which is, okay,
why does this system work?
Okay, so let's do game theory.
Game theory.
Game theory is just a study of how you
how to win games, okay? It's a very
general thing.
So, let's do a thought experiment and
just say there's about a million people
in the world, okay? There's a million
people in the world
and they're all trying to win the game
against each other, but only only one
can win.
Well,
according to game theory, the best way
to win a game is by
Does anyone know?
Cheating, okay?
Cheating. If you follow the rules,
you'll never win the game. You have to
cheat.
And in this game, the best way to win is
by
coordinating with other people, right?
Because everyone's playing by himself.
So, if you can work with other people,
then that gives you a huge advantage
over everyone else, right?
The problem with this is the moment that
people start coordinating, it forces an
arms race of coordination. So, maybe
these two are going together.
These four now are forced to work
together, which now forces these five to
work together.
Okay?
So, if you are the first to work
together, you're get you get screwed in
the process.
So, if you cheat, you have to cheat
secretly.
Okay? You have to coordinate without
people knowing you're actually
coordinating together. You have to
conspire secretly.
Okay? And there are different ways to
collaborate secretly. So, let's let's
look at examples. So, family is one
example, right?
Of coordination. Endogamy.
Another example is religion.
Um if you're a leader,
right? If you um have a similar race,
ethnicity,
you have a sim- similar language.
Okay? So, these are examples of how you
you you you you you you you you you you
you you
The problem is that
these are all obvious to people.
Which forces them to do the same thing.
Okay?
But there's a strategy
that you can use that allows you to
coordinate secretly and defeat all your
enemies. And this strategy is called
transgression.
Transgression.
The breaking of taboos. The breaking of
social norms. The breaking of social
laws.
Transgression.
Okay? So, let's study this concept.
All right. So, the idea is that
um the theory is that
the greater you transgress, okay? This
is the level of transgression.
The greater your cohesion
which leads to synchronicity.
Okay? That's the theory I want to
propose to you.
All right?
So,
transgression, I mean it's it's a very
simple idea. You're breaking the rules,
right? You're cheating. And therefore,
everyone wants to put you in prison.
Which means that the only way that you
can survive is if you keep the secret
among your group.
Right? Which forces cohesion. Does that
make sense?
All right? And we see this in all
aspects of society.
Right? So, the most basic form of
transgression is just joking
or pranking, right? So, for example,
you guys,
six of you,
decide, "You know what? We're going to
play a joke on the school. We're going
to cover all the rooms in with toilet
paper.
It's a joke. It's a prank.
But obviously
you don't want to get caught because the
school will punish you.
And this joke and this prank will make
you more cohesive, right? Because now
you have a secret among amongst
yourself. And if anyone betrays
you, you're all screwed.
Right? Does that make sense? That's the
logic.
Um the other thing that's really
interesting is that
when you transgress, when you break a
taboo, you feel
empowered.
You feel liberated.
And it becomes addictive.
Right? You fill the school with toilet
paper. You're like, "That was a lot of
fun." Why was it fun? Because
you broke the rules. You feel, "I'm more
powerful than my teacher."
Then so you keep on doing more more of
this stuff, right? Then you might be
like, "Hey, let's go to store and steal
a candy." That candy may cost $1,
nothing, right? But you try it
and you are terrified. You're seized by
doubt. You're seized by fear.
Sorry. So um this is the
um sound that tells us that we should go
on break. But but again, we don't go on
break in this class, okay? So I
apologize. We're not We're not taking a
break. We keep on going, okay? But
that's what the sound is.
Okay. So
um
you're terrified because your mother,
your teachers, everyone told you
stealing is bad.
Right? But when you actually go and do
it, how do you feel? You feel energized.
You feel liberated. You feel empowered.
And if your friends who are with you how
the friends becomes much more unified,
much more cohesive, much more
synchronized. Does that make sense?
And now you want to like, let's break
more rules. Let's see what happens if we
break more and more rules. And you keep
on going because it's addictive. And
ultimately, there's a transgression that
is the ultimate taboo, which is what?
You guys know?
Yeah, right? This.
Right?
Can you think of a more
worse transgression than this?
That's why they do it.
Because it feels empowering. It releases
energy. They do it because they believe
that when you do this, it releases
divine energy.
And when you when you actually do it,
okay? I'm guys, I'm not telling you to
go do this, okay? Please do not do this.
Okay? And please remember, okay? This is
evil. We should not be doing this.
But,
when you actually go and do it, those
who can do it, they feel as though they
are now
inundated. That now they are now filled
with divine energy.
They found the secret of the universe.
They found the ultimate power in the
world.
Another transgression, which is not as
bad, but pretty bad, is the idea of
incest, right? And there are secret
societies out there, guys,
that do this.
And you know what, guys?
I I hate to tell you this, okay? But
they do it in public in front of
everyone else.
Because that creates both group unity,
synchronicity, and it releases, in their
minds, divine energy.
They've now access to
God.
If you want to know what secret
societies do,
well,
um yeah.
This and this, okay?
And again, this is only a small group of
people. But now we know why these people
control the world. Because they're able
to keep secrets. Because they're more
motivated than everyone else.
And they're able to work together
in a way that allows them to achieve
ultimate power.
Do these leaders you see, right? These
leaders you see, they are puppets.
They are just a face. The real power are
the secret societies that practice these
rituals. And again, I'm not saying this
is the truth. I'm just saying this is a
possible theory about how the world
works, right? Because this is a class of
speculation. It's a class of theory.
Don't think this is the truth, okay? But
you can think about how this works and
ask yourself,
does it explain the world?
Okay?
All right. So, having explained this,
what I want to do now is go into the
deep theory as to why this is happening.
Okay? So, if you talk to these people
and they're honest with you,
they they'll tell you that when we do
this, we access God and God gives us
divine power. Because they're
superstitious and they're stupid.
Okay? Just because they're the elite,
just because they're powerful people,
does not mean they're clever. In fact,
they're kind of stupid if you actually
meet them. Right? But um I'm going to
explain how this system works.
And when I do it when I explain to you,
it will make sense.
Okay, but are we are we clear so far
about what's happening, guys?
All right? I know this is disturbing and
I know
I I'll probably get banned on YouTube
for this, but it's important that that
that we do this, okay? All right. So,
now I'll explain the theory as to why
this is happening. How is a
transgression is able to unleash divine
energy?
Okay.
So,
um
Kant.
We will look at some major thinkers.
And
um they're really deep thinkers and
we'll go deep we'll go more into them
this semester, but I'm going to
introduce them, okay? So, Kant.
Remember from the first class, Kant had
a theory of how the world works.
There is no objective reality that we
see, okay? So, before the assumption was
that we just absorb reality. Okay? But,
Kant says that we are active
Sorry. We'll we'll we'll wait for this.
So,
Kant says that we are active
participants in reality. How? Well,
because our brains are filters.
We add space and time to reality. Space
and time does not exist outside of us.
Okay?
So, the objective reality is called
noumena.
Okay? The things in themselves. Do not
worry about these names. But, this is
the objective reality.
What happens is that through our
filters, we interact with the noumena
and that creates something called the
phenomena.
The things that we see, the phenomena.
Okay? And that's the world we know.
The noumena we can never ever know.
That's the theory of Kant. Okay? And
this has been confirmed by neuroscience.
So, this is basically the most accurate
model of the world that we have.
The problem though is that Kant's
conception of the world creates three
questions.
Okay? The first question then first
question is, what is the noumena?
Kant says we can never know it, but we
still want to know it. Okay? That's the
first question.
Second question then is, who gave us
these filters?
Right? Where do our filters come from?
How do our minds work and who created
our minds in the first place? That's the
second question. The third question is
if we are all seeing the world for our
own lens, how do we know that we're
seeing the same world?
How do our perception of the world align
together?
Okay?
So, Kant creates these problems. Hegel
who comes after
Kant, Frederick Hegel by the way,
he proposes a solution to this, to these
three problems. And what he says is
this.
And this is really important for us to
understand is the noumenal is the Geist.
The Geist is
hard to translate. We usually translate
it to mean spirit.
Okay? So, what Hegel is saying is that
the spirit world is what creates the
material world.
We are just a shell. What really matters
is the spirit world.
Now, it's really important to understand
the concept of the Geist, okay? And
again, there's it's German, but there's
no actual English translation for it.
So, it's best to see Geist as a
combination of three words
that derive from Geist, okay? These
three words are
ghost,
geyser,
and gist, okay?
So, these two English words
are derivatives of the German word
Geist.
Right? Most words in English are
actually German in origin. Sorry, not
not most words, but many words, okay?
All right. Ghost is just a parallel
reality that exists alongside us, right?
A spiritual world.
That's the first concept. Geyser is just
a force that is exploding or becoming or
expanding.
Okay, so this Geist is constantly
expanding and becoming.
Geist just just means the essence of
things, the core of things.
Okay? So, the real truth in the world is
the Geist. Not what we see, but what is
invisible to us. Okay, so that's the
idea of the Geist. Does that make sense?
Now, the Geist we can answer all three
questions. The noumena, the real world,
is a spiritual, not a material world.
It's the Geist
that gives us these filters.
And because we're all seeing the world
through the Geist,
we see the same world.
Okay?
So, now this creates another problem,
which is
where did the Geist come from?
What is the Geist?
Okay? And here we will look at
Plato and Dante.
Okay? So, um
um again, this is a really deep theory,
and we'll go more deeply into this as
the semester um
moves, but I just first want to
introduce the idea to you right now,
okay? So, this comes from Plato
and a religion called Gnosticism.
Okay? The Gnostics. Uh Gnostic just
means knowledge.
Okay.
Um so, in the beginning, the Big Bang,
the force
is the monad
or the
uh
the one.
Okay, there are different names for this
thing.
Or nous.
Just think of this as a supreme god,
okay? The Big Bang.
The the the force
all the like like the the the sun
almost, okay? The spiritual sun of the
universe.
The Nous works by breathing. When he
breathes, he vibrates his divine power.
And through this, he creates new beings
called dyads.
Dyads are just pairs
of
um
forces, okay? These dyads then create
different realities.
All right? So, different realities are
being created through this inaction.
And eventually, you reach Earth.
Okay?
So, in other words, what Plato and
Gnostics are telling us is that the
Geist
is a multi-layer,
multi-dimensional
world
that we access all the time.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
And the Earth, what we see, it is just
the the most outer shell
in this
universe.
Is this clear to you guys?
All right. So, now
the question then is
what is the purpose of life in the
world? And what Plato says is that the
purpose of life in this world is to
return
to the monad.
Okay? And guess what, guys?
This is actually the
um framework for a lot of religions,
including Hinduism, right? And Buddhism.
This This is what the Hindus
and the Buddhists believe as well.
Nirvana is to return to the monad. I'm
not sure if you guys have studied
religion before, okay? But that's the
idea.
So, what Plato says is that through the
pursuit of knowledge, philosophy, the
love of knowledge, you can return to the
monad.
Okay?
Um Dante
and we will study Dante in depth
later on, okay? But Dante has another
solution.
What Dante Dante says is that the monad
the monad is love.
Okay? And the monad, because he creates
things, his divine spark emanates
throughout
the universe.
Okay? So, there is a divine spark in us.
And this divine spark is called love.
So, we are able to love
people, mothers love children,
you love each other because of this
divine spark in you. And the more you
love,
the more you return to the monad.
Okay? So, Plato says, pursue knowledge.
Dante says, pursue love.
Okay?
So, now the question is, okay, this
sounds all very good,
but
why does evil happen in the world?
Okay, what's the source of evil?
Right? That's interesting, okay. You
have you have this theory of the
universe, but then the question then is,
why do people do bad things then?
Why is there sacrifice in the world? Why
why are people doing all these bad
things and not only getting away getting
away with it, but they're also
controlling the world?
That's a big question, right?
So,
um
for Plato, the answer is very simple.
This world doesn't matter. Who cares if
they control this world? It's a fake
shadow world.
Ignore them. Just focus on the pursuit
of knowledge because that allows you to
be one with the monad.
Okay? Who cares about this world? Give
them what they want. Give them their
power, their fame, their money. Who
cares?
Dante's answer is actually very
interesting, okay? That's That's Plato's
answer. It doesn't matter. This world
doesn't matter. Who cares what happens
in this world? It's a prison anyway.
Dante actually proposed something
different. He says this.
If the monad is love,
love is trust.
So, the monad loves us
and as a result, the monad gives us free
will.
Now, free will can lead to bad things,
for example, this world, but he has no
choice in the matter.
Because for him to interfere
means to take away our free will. And
that's And free will is his greatest
gift to us.
Okay?
But, now and then, what he will do is he
will send messengers to our world to
remind us that there is a divine spark
in us and we can activate it and achieve
a greater consciousness. And these
messengers are
Plato,
Dante,
right?
Jesus,
Does it make sense?
So, now and then the monad will send
um poltergeist, okay? The monad will
implant ideas in these people who will
then
tell us the truth.
It But, it's our choice whether or not
to believe it because the monad has
given us free will.
All right, so
for Plato, what's important is the
pursuit of knowledge. For Dante, what
matters is the pursuit of love, to love
each other unconditionally.
Okay?
Um and that's what they tell us.
What this system also tells us is that
the powerful
want to deny the system.
Right? Because if they control Earth,
the fake world, they want to make it as
real as possible.
Does that make sense?
That's the source of the power. The
belief that the only thing that matters
is the material world, the prison that
we live in.
And that's why we have
science.
Right? Science is negation of the
spiritual world
and the validation of the material
world. If you cannot see it, it must be
fake.
Right?
Okay? So, that's how power works.
Now,
transgression
works in this model because
transgression allows the powerful to
align to a certain part of this
universe, okay? Because in this
universe, there are evil forces as well.
Does that make sense? So, for example,
the metaphor is think of the internet.
Right? Well, there are millions and
millions of websites. And through
transgression, by doing the same evil
act, what the powerful have done is
they've locked onto the same website.
Right? And because they've locked on the
same website, it allows for
synchronicity. It allows for them to
commit
uh to think
alike and to behave the same way.
Okay?
All right. So,
that's the general theory.
And again, this is all speculation. I'm
not telling you this is true,
but I'm giving you a framework to work
with to better understand why things
happen. We're just speculating. We're
using our imagination here.
Right?
I know this is a lot, but Kant, Plato,
Hegel, Dante, we will go much more
deeper into over the semester. I just
introduced these ideas
now.
Okay. Questions, guys?
Okay.
You You had a question from last class,
right?
Right. So So So So can you ask a
question from last class and I'll answer
it first?
All right. From last class you mentioned
that um the ones that control society
are those old pensioners, right? Because
they get revenues from the youngers and
they control the society.
Um in our society I do see signs or
phenomena that um the government are
sort of helping the old pensioners by
creating more um say entertainment or
facilities that benefit them.
So why is that? Is it possible that the
the government also benefits benefits
from
old pensioners' actions or is actually
the governments are controlled by old
pensioners?
Yeah, I mean we did we discuss this last
class, but it's the pensioners, they're
old people who control society, control
the culture, who control government.
Right? Because in China, from the first
day you're taught to respect your
elders, right? You're taught that old
peop- elderly people are worth um
emulating, they're worth they're worth
studying from, they're they're what's
most precious about our society. So it
makes sense that the government would
create policies to most benefit
the elderly.
Okay? That's That's That's just the
structure of Chinese society.
Respect for the elderly.
Okay?
Thank you. Any more questions, guys?
Yep.
Um Amber has a question.
Yeah.
Um so I was just thinking about the
model and I think
>> The monad. Uh yeah, this model that we
have on the board. Um, so, like you
said, the existence of evil is
if you don't mind repeating yourself.
Oh, yeah. So, what is evil? Yeah. Okay,
in in the system. Okay, so, um, in this
system, what is evil is the denial of
the system.
Okay? Okay. So, because the monad is the
truth, it's love, right? So, the closer
you move to the monad, that's what's
good. The further you move away from the
monad, that's what's evil. Right? So, at
the very end of this model is Earth. So,
the more you embrace material world,
the more you
deny the spiritual world, that's what's
evil in this in in this model. Okay.
>> So, for Plato, the what's good is the
pursuit of knowledge. And what's evil is
the pursuit uh, the denial of the of
knowledge, which includes, by the way,
art.
Right? Movies. Because movies are just
a shadow of the shadow world. We live
The world we live live in is fake, and
movies, all they do is
depict this fake world, then it makes
things worse.
Mhm. Okay? And Dante,
uh, whatever
um, allows for more love is good. What
allows for less love is
bad. Okay.
>> Okay? Um, so, just to add on to that.
So, what if, um, like we mentioned
earlier, sacrifice sacrifice can be
considered as a way to unite people. It
creates cohesion. Yeah. And with
cohesion, it unlocks divine energy
because you're accessing a part of this
model. Okay. Yeah. Does that make sense?
Mhm, yeah. Right? And And that's why, as
you're doing this
sacrifice, they're worshipping a certain
god.
Uh-huh. Right? So, sacrifice is part of
their religion. It's not done
independently.
They have a religious framework for the
sacrifice.
And that's why they do it.
Right? They don't do sacrifice for
personal sacrifice. They do sacrifice
um as a consummation of their religion
because that's what their religion
demands of them. Mhm. Right? And because
they worship a god, they sacrifice these
people to send to this god. Okay. Right?
So, they're accessing a part of this
model, which is a lower
part, okay?
>> And there are there are evil beings in
this model as well, right?
But but they go lower.
Okay. So, by
I'm trying to
So, by
being evil, we're like doing the bad
deeds, we get as long as it creates love
in Dante's theory, it gets us ultimately
closer to the To the monad, yes.
But the evil now that we perceive is
constructed by our current society.
So,
Yeah. So, what Dante is saying about
current society is that our society is
first and foremost anti-love. It does
not allow for people to love each other.
So, for example, school, right?
>> Mhm. So,
um without school,
your parents would just care about your
happiness. Mhm.
But because of school, parents
care about your grades
and whether or not you get into a elite
American college Mhm. and whether or not
you get a good job.
And so, the parents deny your free will.
They deny your agency.
And as a result, you don't feel loved.
Okay?
So, that's what Dante would argue. Our
society
is anti-love
because
the society is constructed in a way that
does not allow for normal human
relationships to flourish. Mhm. Right?
In a normal relationship, your parents
would just let you do whatever you want.
I would think, you know?
But because they're like, "No, no, no.
If I let you do whatever you want, you
will not do well in school, and you
won't be able to get a job, and then
you'll become
I don't know, unemployed and a drug
addict. Who knows, okay?"
Right? That's how they think.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
So, the denial of free will is
anti-love, and therefore it's evil, and
maybe it limits Yeah, it limits you from
getting closer to Monad. That's right.
Okay, great. Exactly. Thank you.
Yep.
But just like the uh what Amber mentions
that this world is anti-love, but what
is the purpose of like not letting us
get closer to the Monad?
Well, you That's a good question, right?
Why are they doing this? Because the
people in power want to stay in power.
Right? Because what they're doing it
goes against the Monad.
But
they want to stay in power. So, they
gain like benefits such as power by
disobeying the Monad and letting others
like disobeying the Monad because they
can keep their power. Okay, so so let so
let let let us be very clear, okay? This
is really important.
Different people will interpret this
model in a different way.
Okay? In their conception, the Monad's
the evil one.
Their god's the good one.
They're liberating us from the Monad by
making us more focused on the material
world.
Okay? Does that make sense? But the
reality is that
they were able to get their power
because
they were They had a religion that
promoted transgression, which allowed
them to coordinate well together. And
now that they have this power, they need
to rationalize why they have this power,
and they need to develop systems to
maintain this power. That's why we have
the world we live in today. Does that
make sense?
Okay? Does that make sense?
They're powerful, they want to maintain
the power, so they will think of new
ideas that allow them to keep this
power, even if it means denying the
truth, okay?
And and again, guys, this is a theory,
no one knows if this is true or not.
I don't know.
But like what you just mentioned that
monad has two meanings to
either
>> No, no, no. The monad does not have two
meanings. It has one. It has different
names, but one meaning.
Okay, this is really important for you
to understand. There are different names
for this, but it is the sun.
Okay? The divine sun, the source of all
life. So, Plato defines monad as
knowledge, and Dante defines monad as
love. No. No, no, no. Okay,
listen, okay, you have to get this
straight, okay? This is everything,
okay? Love, knowledge, everything, okay?
The question that Plato and Dante are
debating is how do you return to the
monad?
Okay? So, for Plato, it's the pursuit of
knowledge that allows you to get closer
to the monad. For Dante, it's the
pursuit pursuit of love.
Okay? But this is the one and all, the
infinite and eternal.
What Plato would say is that this is the
perfect.
This is the immutable. It will never
change. And it's the eternal. It's
always been there, and it will always be
there.
Okay? It's really similar to Buddhism,
right? It is exactly Buddhism.
>> looking at the same thing. It's like
more spiritual aspect of
the world and like the ultimate end of
things. It's more like abstract concept.
It's not something physical that we can
interpret as one thing or another.
>> Yeah, this is exactly what is in
Hinduism, okay? So this is really
interesting how different religious
traditions
working in different localities have the
same conception
of the world, of the universe. And
can we can we get someone else an
opportunity to to speak, please? Okay?
Can can can someone else ask ask
question?
Like like like I know I know you're
enthusiastic, but sometimes you want to
step back and absorb the idea, okay? So
so you've asked a lot of questions, but
go home, think about this some more.
Okay? Does that Does that make sense?
Okay. Does Does anyone
want to else want to ask questions?
Okay, one more question, okay?
One more So like just to confirm that
Okay.
Uh Plato and Dante just like gives us
the way to approach monad, right?
Okay.
Um can can you ask the question again? I
I I I don't Like I want to confirm that
Plato or Dante they because they don't
Plato said that to learn knowledge and
Dante said to pursue love, so they gives
the way to let to let us approach monad,
right? So the monad in the conception of
everything is the same, okay?
It is a source of everything.
Plato and Dante are proposing different
ways to to become closer to the monad,
right?
For Plato, it's like spend your entire
life learning mathematics, specifically
geometry.
Because he thinks that geometry is
really the language of of the universe,
the secret language of the universe.
Dante says, "That's too hard, guys.
That's not intuitive."
Like for Play- Plato's an elitist,
right? Plato is like only if you come to
my school and you learn geometry, sacred
geometry, will where access heaven.
Donny is like, "That makes no sense. The
monad would not create a system which
only the elite the chosen could access
him. The monad, if he truly loves
everyone, will give everyone the
capacity
to reach him. And that capacity that
that is accessible to everyone is love,
right? Doesn't matter who you are,
you can all love.
But
quite honestly, there are there are not
that many people in the world who can do
calculus, right?
Right? So, Plato's like, "You have to do
calculus." Plato is like and Donny is
like, "That's just ridiculous.
That's the most ridiculous thing in the
world."
Okay?
Does that make sense now?
Okay.
Um any more questions, guys?
It's like, why is that like a lot of
other like religions and, you know,
Plato or like Dante, they came to the
same realization of monad? Like, why is
that? Like, it's from different places
in the world, different regions, but
like, why do they all have kind of the
same thing about wisdom or like
knowledge in general? Yeah. So, so
um that's a really good question and the
answer is the geist, right? The answer
is where do our thoughts come from and
where do our thoughts go? Do you really
think that it's our brain that produces
thoughts?
Why is it that with the same brain,
right? Same neurological neurological
structure,
but we have different ideas?
And why is it that I have so many ideas
and you and others have limited ideas?
Well,
like biologically, we cannot explain it,
okay? We've never explained it. So, if
you if you study neuroscience, one thing
they will never ever ask is, "Where do
our thoughts come from?" Which is weird
because that should be the most basic
question, right? That's the first
question you ask, but they never ask
that. Why? Because they cannot answer
it.
And the answer, the possibility is the
geist exists and our ideas come from the
geist.
And we think of ideas, it goes back into
the Geist.
Right? It's a ghost. It is with us and
it's not with us.
There's just like a big system out there
that everything comes from there and so
all of these things will go back there
eventually. Is exactly. Exactly. And and
that's and and that's why and that's how
we can explain why all these different
religions have the same conception of
the universe.
Because they're getting this conception
through inspiration, right? Through
communication with the Geist.
Right? Does that make sense?
Okay.
I I think that makes a lot more sense
than oh, the synapses in our brains, you
know?
They fire together and they hit and like
oh, we have an idea.
I don't know.
Okay.
Okay. All right. So, great. Uh we will
continue this next class.
Okay.